keep adesso it's 1,500 kilometers its
technical difficult and without external
resources glass Excel organization can't
afford to do that i will say that today
the partners from the eastern you can
read from the others are even more
willing to cooperate today then from the
western ukraine that's the reason that
this photo was even used to go pray and
it's nothing strange for that
once technical knowledge and this is I
would say the biggest
trying to direct trains from baa2 to use
them to continue when you have direct
train to okay start to Center up all
here to have several times today takia
but there is no way to the direct line
to move our session comment this issue
of cultural heritage management of Prada
and I would have said five or eight
years ago we open borders everyone keeps
what they have and takes care of it but
now I begin to wonder whether
internationalisation the issue might not
be but that is we have a government in
Ukraine which has relatively little
interesting also narrative any and we
have a situation in the famous also
linnaean collection view where their
probable preservation of materials I
believe that collection should stay
where it is but I believe that it is not
a matter not only to poles but of the
international community not a matter of
indifference that if you preserves out
or in corresponding way have you been in
there might not have been the
destruction of the people in potential
at that point where the major conserve
our opponents and don't do it and the
Carmelites didn't have that issue at
international repercussions either
improve joint pregnant polish
Commission's or some general European
Commission I think they were stopping
our lives at that point and I wonder if
if you peer through your experience what
you see are there any ways in which this
is done now at ease by national
conditions or through some general
UNESCO efforts to make sure that there
is the bestest most important parish me
nor puppet so I pop in the mid section
of the Torah super super easy to predict
ago the Paramecium on the more that we
would ' course because no and said
increasing that's why it that's what you
did normally sure what you gonna put you
from the opening just give me a little
mini volatility he forced you out of
school until invalid to support people
among us telepacific esq brother I their
career with us father it was magic
second was Trevor cuz they're always
imagined second was Trevor Moore the
general market incitement to swamp or
you were serious obably up to a step or
11 years of every quiver that he would
have put the auditions and it's a group
were previously for ski Jessica move it
traumatic is entirely about the
political animal really proud of
struggling in a m'allister is assimilate
America the national television is a
semi and the same stretch maybe we have
on the side the potential somebody might
help
that you cannot do things the pole it
has certain say over monuments at my
charger collagen oh and you reckon
territory and Ukraine as a certain say
that needs to be consulted with Mike
then stocks I would say there are two
elements the one is over patent on those
sides and you can give examples but we
will need it today throughout history
and police yesterday the other problem
is just the problem of the power of the
states and financial possibilities they
are unequal as evil the Polar Star you
do not have enough money it's not that
excuse for the charity case of the
challenge places to show the case of
eternity but the question of solar the
question of
the leaves are salsas the office
contacts to more music
by the time
thank you while very brief pause before
we went to external